[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 159 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mach Mandel and as always I'm here
with my colleague Melanie Warwick hey
you know Melanie hey Marc I'm good how
are you doing I'm doing are I so I'm
hanging out in Seattle you are and I'm
in San Francisco yes I'm back you're
back where are you at mark I'm at coop
Cohen I'm in here at guca Thank You Khan
it's my first coop Khan I'm very excited
that's awesome and all the people are
there we were saying we were saying
earlier before we started recording all
the cool people are there yeah all the
cool kubernetes people that's right
other cool people there are definitely
other cool groups there are yeah well
okay mark it's our end of your wrap-up
it's our last episode for the year 2018
yeah we're gonna go through all the
stuff that we liked about this year and
all the stuff that everyone from our
listeners like from this year I realized
we probably should have done that all
the things we don't like from this year
- okay just to shake it up a little bit
but yes we were gonna talk about all the
top 10 and some of our favorites from
the cool things of the week yep but
before we get into that as always we
will do the last cool things of the week
for 2018 and we have a question of the
week for this year which is what were
your personal highlights for 2018 yes
all the things 2018 well great so let's
get into the cool things that week what
is the cool thing of the week for you
mark well cool thing of the week is
definitely that there is a whole stack
of Googlers at cube khand doing a wide
variety of things so there's a booth
there sessions there's workshops some of
which will have already started by the
time this comes out but when this comes
out I'll be doing mentoring sessions on
the Wednesday so you probably would have
missed the one in the morning but you
may still catch the one in the afternoon
I'll be speaking on Wednesday as well
about a gun is but there's yeah there's
there's a wide variety of Google stuff
going on which is pretty awesome
it was pretty awesome it's my first coop
con I'm very excited well how long has
this conference been going on
I wouldn't say like four years I could
be wrong I could be doing like I can't
believe this is your first one yeah very
exciting and on that vein there is a
blog post that goes along with this
there's a kubernetes and gke for
developers a year of cloud console so
basically this is actually a really nice
summary of cloud console that exists for
gke and what it does so starting your
cluster and then once it's up and
running being able to have a look inside
it and see metrics or
CPU and memory and what's coming on
internally and what things are running
and then also having access to the cloud
marketplace and be able to drop things
in from there it's just a really cute
little article talking about all the
things you can do on gke that are
integrated directly into the cloud
console as well which is just a nice
touch for a cute car
it's very nice another cool thing of the
week is reducing gender bias and Google
Translate we got an announcement post
out there that is talking about how
Google's efforts to promote fairness and
reduce bias machine learning there's
been changes that allow Translate to
provide feminine masculine translations
for some gender-neutral words so
especially words like surgeon that will
now be translated from English into
French or Italian or Portuguese or
Spanish so you can get both and that
example is already out there and you can
read about it and check it out yeah I
like this it's being essentially
monolingual not being used to having
languages have like feminine and
masculine yeah yeah it's a blind spot
and so it's really good to see this
coming through I agree and another thing
we wanted to mention is a blog post
that's out there around cloud security
command center and that it's now in beta
and so that is out there it's providing
a number of new features that include
expanding coverage across GCP services
like datastore DNS load balancing
spanner container registry kubernetes
engine and virtual private cloud yeah
this is great I love this turn of phrase
like if you need a central place to
understand your security posture which I
really like
this is this is the view for you I know
I heard that recently actually from our
colleague Jen yes security posture it's
a good word Edward but yeah let's you
assess your security risks and
vulnerabilities from a single place and
you can see your assets and integrate
security flying's from a variety of
security leaders including Google
themselves so yeah if you're into
security which I think we all are it's a
great name to check out at this point
especially it's expanded into client
libraries including Java a node and goes
yeah you can go online you can see what
it provides and see how you'd need
engage with it excellent
all right well why don't we go talk
about all our favorite things from this
year yes let's go talk to ourselves is
it so it's the end of 2018
it's our wrap-up segment it is it's a
recap episode I can't believe it's
already the end Wow time flies happy
holidays happy
Happy Hanukkah happy Festivus happy all
the things yes all the things cleanses
us now too happy that yes yep whenever
you want to celebrate or if you don't
you just want to sit around and watch
Netflix all day have a good one
definitely do that that sounds great I'm
gonna do that I just plugged for them
too and we're not getting paid by them
yeah excellent so as per tradition over
the last few years we like to do a
wrap-up episode where we talk about all
the things that happened 2018 so to
start this off we actually want to talk
about some of the the actual podcast
accomplishments yeah a year so a couple
of the things that come to mind are the
new intro and outro music we got from
our editor we're really grateful for yep
we have a brand new website company
Pawnee and Booth did that for us yes
gorgeous it looks great and we have new
YouTube videos yeah we have an internal
team that works on that now and they do
a much better job than we did ourselves
definitely yeah it looks gorgeous also a
lot of new photos that we captured for
the year which we've been using because
we know many people were saying Melanie
you're not princess we had to do a photo
shoot it was terrible we had to be the
center of attention
remember really ill at the time the show
must go on
better cut other accomplishments for the
year February 20th we hit 1 million
downloads
yeah and just recently we hit 2 million
downloads December 1st high-five
high-five and Mark you and the podcast
celebrated three years you were never
gonna leave so yes it's been a lot of
accomplishments this year it's been a
good run plus while we're recording this
we mentioned we are over 2 million
downloads we're at like 2 million 5,000
downloads and you'd mentioned about 1
million 1.1 million downloads this year
so far yeah it's pretty great the
directory is in the listenership if the
podcast has definitely been up into the
ride so thank you to everyone for
listening here thank you thank you for
all the guests and we're gonna do our
top 10 top 10 most downloaded episodes
yes oh my god and we start from the top
from 10 and countdown we've got it
together today yeah anyway so yeah top
10 most downloaded a lot of them came
from this year actually yeah I think
almost all of them almost all with the
exception of one alright but we won't
tell you which one no you have to find
out yes okay so number 10 starting from
the bottom or the top depends how you
look at it it's fine
my favorite people Sarah Novotny and who
has come to join us the head of
open-source strategy at Google cloud I'm
such a huge fan of Sarah's me too
I really really am such a delight and a
pleasure to spend time with her on the
podcast talking about open source
talking about the history of Cuban
Nettie's Sarah's been around since the
beginning of communities all the way
through to like the creation of CN CF so
it's Sarah is just a wealth of
information about open source and open
source strategy it's such a it's such a
privilege actually to have her in our
company and being able to ask your
questions about these things and talk to
her about open source and open sourced
rata G agreed it was it was a wonderful
episode our number nine episode is from
episode 130 and this were a couple of
friends and colleague Juliette Hoagland
and Michelle Casman were joined us to
talk about data science so we got a
chance to talk about what is data
science what are some of the toolings
just some of the challenges the benefits
how its applied it was a great episode I
was grateful that we could get them on
yeah and the first time I think that
Michelle cast wanna has been on the
episode but she has been on a few times
since then yes she has she came back to
help out with some of the rappers
recently which was great number eight
for most downloaded launchpad studio
with Malika Cantor and Peter Norvig yeah
this is our first episode of this year
really that was our first episode of the
show yeah is that yeah I was I was very
excited that we got them on for this
episode in particular yeah yeah no it
was a really good episode launchpad
studios does a lot of work with startups
and there was sort of this really
interesting cross-pollination between
they were talking about you know AI
startups and startup culture and how the
technology of AI
has changed so much that has enabled
that space to really open up and be
explored and they're pushed especially
to be able to make that accessible those
types of tooling machine learning in
particular accessible to smaller groups
so that was something that we got a
chance to dive into and I'm glad we were
able to have them on yeah it was really
good
number seven yes number seven number
seven so this wasn't recorded this year
but I think it's been around for a long
time so this is Tim Hawking talking
about kubernetes 1.7 your favorite thing
my favorite thing proven it easy this
was the episode that was holding the
number one spot up until this year yeah
for a really long time yeah I think this
is testament to a couple of things one
of which is you know people love
kubernetes and that's great people also
really liked him yeah people really
liked him to me if you're listening you
should feel really good about that
I think that's definitely something that
that's kept this episode going for such
a long time at such a high spot you know
in our downloads yeah the six-month
downloaded podcast was episode number
113 and that was with EFE Fang and we
were talking about open source
tensorflow so this actually was holding
our number three spot for a while and it
recently was unseated I was watching
that and I was it was really impressed
by it she got into open source she got
into the tooling and open source working
with the community what that means and
and just talking about the challenges
and the interesting values that you know
you get out of working with an open
source so it was great to speak with her
and have her on I really like this one
because so often with large open source
projects there's so much automation and
so many tools that happen behind the
scenes to make sure everything runs in
the way it's opposed to within the
community and help out all the people
who are authors and developers and
contributors and people who provide
feedback and I think sometimes it gets a
little hidden and I so it was really
nice to to bring it to the front and
sort of talk about the tooling that has
to happen for these sort of scale of
projects to deal with the scale of
contribution that it's happening and and
how to manage that so that people can
kind of do the things that they're good
at as humans and robots can kind of do
the things that they're good at - Oh
[Music]
v GM loaded is episode 128 yeah
season intelligence with Cassie cassava
yes I hope I got your name she's very
steeped deep into the decisions
intelligence space and was able to come
on and talk to us about the importance
of it what it means how valuable it is
in particular in the machine learning
and AI space yeah Cassie is the chief
decision engineer at Google Cloud and
she works a lot with customers to
basically help them make decisions about
how their data can make decisions
essentially which is crucial for applied
especially but she has a great
background with helping people
understand these complex concepts
especially when it comes to to
statistical and inference and just other
additional technological concepts in
relation to decision intelligence yeah
yeah absolutely absolute number 4
episode number 4 - wonderful teammates
of ours Seth and Liz come on to battle
it out about what is better sre or
DevOps
everything it's a battle of the ages I
love it yes it was a Throwdown there's a
lot of blood it was great now they
they have a good video series so you
should check out but we we did get into
you know understanding a serene DevOps
in relation to each other separately you
know what that means how to approach it
yeah if you want to see which one wins
you have to listen and some of their
favorite tools and stuff ya know it's a
great it's a great discussion on s re
and F up sculpture all right the top
three up three so number three number
three it she used to be held by FA Jeff
Dean yes talking about Google AI and
this was a great episode where we got
into a number of different subjects you
know we talked about teepee use in the
history of machine learning and AI and
Google and we talked about parallel
processing and his research from back in
the day talked about deep learning in
Java which was a conference he was going
to be speaking at and just the
importance of Africa especially because
there was a recent Research Institute
that was open there we got into a lot
we're going through a lot Melanie asked
Mac to say thank you for setting this up
because it was such a highlight for my
ear
speaking to Jeff it was one of those
conversations I came away with so many
interesting ideas that I didn't know I
was going to get walking in yeah that
and Jeff is such an amazing person it
really was an absolute pleasure to talk
to Jeff and have this conversation and
learned so much even just being the host
yes I feel the same that was a good one
for it to be our number three in the
most downloaded absolutely all right
number two number two per se dad I oh
yeah Mike fought Tanaka switch I hope
I'm not boxing that but anyways Mike
came on early on in the year to talk to
us and so a friend of mine works there
and that's the reason why we've and were
able to get this all set up to begin
with and for those who don't know
so Percy dot IO is a continuous
integration platform specifically
working around visualization so
basically how does my site look has it
changed from how it went to be before
basically a tool to be like is my design
doing the things that it should be doing
has my you exchanged in a way that I'm
not anticipating exactly and the visual
reviews specifically in the the CI space
is very valuable with the way our world
is working this integrates really nicely
with github and Mike went all the way
through like how they use GCP and their
structure and stuff to it was a super
interesting interview it was a great
interview and so it's our second most
downloaded yep and number one ooh big
drumroll
here comes still holding the spot the
spots actually been held for a while
he's been holding it pretty much almost
since February or March of this year it
is Sam Ramji yes he was at the time our
VP of Product Management for Google
cloud platform yep
so this is it this is a really lovely
one as well Sam Sam is a delightful
fellow as well we got into some of his
history like his work at Cloud Foundry
being you know chief strategy officer
for Apogee it was really fascinating
conversation because we got into things
like open source and distributed systems
as well as philosophy yeah we talked
about teen culture and basically like
how people become performers and how to
treat people and yes it was great so if
you want to check out that episode and
you haven't already and Sam if you're
listening I hope you're proud of this
episode I hope all is going well for you
indeed indeed indeed we were also going
to mention what our top 10 were for this
year not for all time yes but we're
gonna just make a side note about this
it's pretty much the same as with one
exception
it was the exception the exception is
that instead of Tim Hawkins being in
number 7 because it was recorded in a
previous year we actually have one of
the other episodes that we were recorded
this year that popped up which is
project Jupiter oh yeah and that was
recorded with Jessica Ford you veve
Panda and Chris hold graph so they were
all members of project Jupiter working
on it they came on to talk to us about
what it is the various products and
services that are provided this is a
tool that's very popular especially in
the data space and you know we had some
good conversations especially around
reproducibility you know some of the
bigger challenges in the data space and
how project Jupiter is working on
addressing those also the most number of
guests we've ever fit inside a podcast
that is the most number of guests I know
you were likely there's two mics now we
made it work and we also talked about
distributed computing and kubernetes -
yeah which is always one of your
favorites always that's a lot that's a
lot maybe we're done we don't know
so what else I talked a little bit about
each other's favorite episodes we did a
lot of episodes this year we do one a
week we did was like 50 episodes and I
had a really hard time picking my top
favorites I know I think we should be
proud of ourselves I think we this is a
really good focus yeah we did do a good
work this year so let's get back to some
Ford's what's one of your favorites
Melanie
for me this year was when we got to
interview dr. Faye Faye Lee about
Claudia she used to be the chief
scientist of AI and ml at Google and
she's returned to being a professor at
the computer science department at
Stanford yep
so that episode we ended like literally
squeezed that one in we barely got that
in in time I wanted to release that for
the week when it was International
Women's Day yep and so you know we
talked to her about the work that she
was doing at the time to make AI
accessible on GCP as well as we talked
about her research in healthcare with AI
so that was a great episode that was a
great episode I'm also trying to avoid
episodes we've mentioned previously cuz
they were all amazing episodes otherwise
I'll just gosh about Sarah Novotny for
an hour yeah probably not that useful um
but to highlight for me definitely
developer relations that we did with
Mandy white yeah Mandy's great she's
been the developer relations game and
also here at Google for a really long
time and just brings a wealth of
experience about developer relations and
why it's important and the team itself
here at Google cloud so it was an
absolute pleasure to spend some time
with her and we get her yeah and just
talk through all that kind of stuff
another highlight for me was when we got
Tanika brew and Margit Mitchell who are
researchers here at Google on the
podcast and at the time actually to meet
was not here she was at Microsoft but we
got them on to talk about machine
learning bias and family such a good
episode
no I we didn't even have to work that
hard for that one knew what needed to be
talked about Rob machine learning bias
and fairness and they just went with it
and yeah you know if you want to
understand that space and understand
some of the challenges in the space as
well as the work that's being done from
a social side as well as an algorithmic
side they both covered it we have a
number of resources we included in that
episodes show notes so yeah it was I was
really glad we got that one together
that's great no I love that episode two
I wanted to put that in my list as well
but you set it up a check of it you can
take I mentioned it okay it's both of
our favorites yeah contributing to
kubernetes yeah miss Harris Pittman and
Garrett Rodriguez just talking through
the contributor experience and how that
gets managed and how they do special
interest groups at kubernetes three days
is such a large open source project so
having an understanding of how the
community works it was super interesting
to hear about and I know there's a lot
of people who were interested in getting
involved in there's so many areas in
which to get involved so I hope that was
valuable resource to everyone who
listened and you got to touch on one of
your favorite topics kubernetes
kubernetes we knew that yeah it was good
to have them on for sure like I want to
put them all on the top here but another
highlight for me was talking to haben
Girma who come on to talk about
accessibility in tech we were able to
capture that podcast in particular
because she spoke at next yep and so she
came on and she was able to you know
talk through some of the importance of
accessibility intact she's the first
deafblind person to graduate from
Harvard Law and she specifically
advocates for equal opportunities for
people with disabilities and so this is
something she was able to speak very
in-depth about with absolute pleasure
absolutely I agree a hundred percent
another hat for you there's another
highlight for me this one I really like
it's the first person who's been able to
do a demo on the podcast oh yeah actions
on Google with Mandy Chan so talking
about voice actions and all the
technology that comes behind voice
actions and because we're an audio only
podcast Mandy could make remember that
day you're like let's try this other
thing out yet yeah it was so much fun
I was such a delight having art and and
again another episode where I walked
away and I was like I need to play with
this yeah I want to do like games with
voices and stuff like this is cool and
her energy about it is very affectionate
Mandy's great thank you for rich coming
on the podcast agreed another habit for
me was talking with Riya Hadsell about
robotics navigation and reinforcement
learning we we were getting that one on
the fly that was one of those that we
thankfully were able to put into our
schedule and the way she covers these
topics was very helpful and insightful
and useful so if you want to hear more
about in just the advances in the field
about robotics learning to navigate new
surroundings she talked specifically
about her research in that recently and
how machine learning is just in essence
helping us to better understand our
minds another highlight for me all that
was a lot we should really draw a line
at some point I know but I want to
mention this one because it's important
they're all important yeah but well yo
we Steven alderman and Eric as Rick oh I
messed that up I'm sorry Eric but this
is a wonderful practical example of how
to apply AI and machine learning to a
particular thing so Willie oh is a
platform that is an intelligent platform
to help people with shopping plan
preparing food and drawing healthy meals
and doing it in a way that like
basically adapts for the users of the
system which is just amazing first of
all but hugely complicated and just so
interesting and so they also break down
their usage of Google cloud and the
technologies they use and how they go
about it it was super good practice what
I appreciated most about that episode
was that they took us through the full
pipeline from literally the data to the
putting it into production it's a nice
full picture yeah how you deal with
especially machine learning from the
start to the finish another highlight
for me I know this is this is a
highlight for you too we got our friend
KF to come on it we talked about
strangely which is the conference where
we all met we talked about you know
remote York we talked about distributed
computing we talked about you know new
people getting into the field and what
that's like we talked about how KF likes
to make fun of me we did talk about how
KF likes having fun of you I know it was
an episode where it's funny because I
really wanted her to come on the podcast
and she initially was a little resistant
to it and then when she finally
committed to doing it you know mark was
also resistant to it because he knew
she'd make fun of him I also recognized
like she has a significant amount of
insights that I'm very yeah grateful for
and I was glad we were able to capture
that episode so if you want to see us
having a fun time with a friend of ours
you can or hear us have a fun time with
a friend of ours you should listen to
the episode number 150 yeah I was gonna
say I got to mention one more highlight
Johnny the highlight in particular is
that I went to South Africa and captured
the deep boning in dhaba Besson so rate
of says you know there's multiple ones
all of them have their own different
values but I was glad I was able to make
that work and get that on the podcast
this year excellent yeah all right
plenty of stuff to listen to if you
haven't I know it's like basically
listen to everything the old stuff just
a little bit it's all good all right so
let's let's change shock a little when
we talk about sort of our favorite
announcements products things that have
happened inside Google cloud that you
thought were particularly cool and
interesting like highlights for you for
2018 sure I'll jump in first so for me I
think you know I do stuff in the games
industry so pretty excited about the
unity in Google cloud
strategic alliance pretty excited about
that announcement coming out I think
there's there's still some stuff coming
out of that and what's going on but the
fact that we're working so closely with
a company like unity in the Unity engine
I think there are some really exciting
things coming down the pipe and we've
started talking about it it's sort of
unites Berlin and you're not la about
projects like reppin match the European
source matchmaking platform there also
go to announce this year and the work
that's happening between unity knows on
them as well as some of the planned
product integrations coming forward - so
pretty excited about sort of the whole
connected games platform yeah we've been
talking about there another highlight
for me that just came to my mind is the
TP use in beta be able to access the TPU
chips and run your programs I know when
they were an alpha you had to go through
an application process but in beta
they made it much more accessible to
those who doing research and I wanted to
you to leverage those with their
tensorflow code another cool thing that
was highlight for us for this year the
Google datasets search in beta as well
dave is always a key thing you need them
for any kind of machine learning you're
doing so having the ability to more
easily find datasets that you can work
with and you can experiment on that was
very much needed I think I'm gonna be on
the games Birkin Record for a bit Birkin
record for a bit Birkin record for a bit
do it
the recent Halloween multiplayer doodle
that worked with urban match iron worked
all on Google Cloud was kind of a just a
really cool game that be also just a
wonderful demonstration of scale so
Google Cloud we served over a hundred
million players a 62 country's current
use alert of over half a million players
during a five minute window at its peak
we supported a Google doodle like that's
the Google homepage that's cool it's
really cool so I just I love it and if
there's some fun that's like a highlight
that I picked up on from necks in
particular was the gke on-prem oh yeah
so many people were excited about that
yeah the possibilities for hybrid cloud
I think are really exciting yes and
lists in some ways it is all about
hybrid cloud at this point yeah GK on
Prem is really exciting yeah I think in
general also just the updates that
continued to roll out about kubernetes
unsurprisingly for me and then flowing
into gke as well you know we're up to
communities about 1.12 off the top my
head that I think 13 is coming out yet
and and seeing more and more features
continue to grow and continue to evolve
in that space and the things that come
on top of them as well I mean we've seen
things like canid
get released this year scaffold sto has
more updates when one point over this
year G visor as well all working in this
sort of containerized cloud native space
that I think it's just kind of growing
incredibly and I was also very excited
when I saw the news that Google AI was
opening up another research group out of
Accra Ghana so that was another
highlight for me for this year yeah
actually we spoke about next just
briefly before but just talking about
next in general next for me was a
highlight that I think it's worth
talking about next was insane it was
great it was just there was so much
going on there was so much going on it's
the biggest event I've ever seen yeah
Google cloud the amount of investment
there and the amount of production and
the amount of announcements there's a
lot of customers oh my and then you and
I recorded like a I'm just just linking
through to the blog post where it's 105
announcements from Google cloud next
yeah like three or four buildings it was
Wow there was a lot going on and they're
gonna do it all over again in April
that's that's very close that's a lot
sooner than I think we should we should
definitely sleep for the next couple of
weeks
oh my yeah that's coming up soon too but
ya know and you spoke about a little
just you know doing stuff on the show
floor and recording so much it's such a
delight to meet out listeners and yes
physically see them in the same place
and be able to talk to them and stuff so
yeah yeah I was pleasantly surprised by
how many people came in just to tell us
thank you
so that was really nice and like I
listened to you all I wash my dishes you
know it was really cool and you got
everyone chocolate I did get everyone
chocolate and and I was shocked by how
many people wanted our t-shirts because
that last day like there was a line
there was an actual line I was like do
you guys even know what you're lining up
for it but t-shirts Epiphany they didn't
care at one point when we didn't have
the sizes anymore that people could you
know choose from they just took whatever
we had so that was nice that was really
nice and and a fun experience because
when you're in a booth like this and
you're just talking and it's like you
and your head listening and then you're
like oh no yeah I know I really love
specially love hearing the stories from
people who are like I wasn't gonna come
to next but I listen to the podcast and
now I'm here or we started using GCP
because of the podcast or things like
that a lot of people have also said help
for them just have an understanding a
basic here's how we go about approaching
GCP to begin with yes thank you all
right mark I think that covers it in
terms of at least the top ten highlights
and our highlights and all the
highlights all the fun stuff for the
year I've really enjoyed being on the
podcast I've really enjoyed having you
on I am going to tell everyone at this
point that I am actually going to be
leaving the podcast next year very sad I
know it was been fun I'm really glad I
got to do this we are working on getting
other people who will be coming on we're
actually gonna change it up a little bit
next year so this is not going away
there's more to come and you will find
out more about that later yeah we'll
have some pretty good announcements I
think pretty exciting out so it should
2018 for the podcast
yeah so definitely stay tuned yeah
thanks for everybody for embracing me as
being your second co-host considering
princess was such an amazing one big
shoes to fill
yeah but both a delight and a pleasure
today well always welcome back thank you
always always always do we think
ourselves I was just thinking that well
thank you Mark and Melanie for coming on
the push yes you did an excellent job
well yes well done that's well done us
so anyway
mark yes last question for the year yes
which is what was your personal
highlights for 2018 personal highlights
for 2018 for me I think studying the
projective Gunnar's that's been a really
big thing for me and really excited
about it and working with the people
I've been working with I'm in the
contributors they come on board and
working with Ubisoft and just helping
build that as a community and the
product has been super rewarding I'm
just amazed at how that's been going so
super super excited what would you say
is your favorite part about all of that
like it's you the most excited about it
actually I think for me actually it is
the interaction with the community it's
when somebody comes on board they're
like I built a thing or here's a pull
request it's such a lovely feeling when
someone's like you did a thing and I
liked it and also here's the thing I'm
giving you back and you're like oh my
God we're gonna like build things
together and I just left that
collaboration other cool things other
cool things I love the new website
franceska I did I think Ashley France
listed most of it but it did a great job
with yes job we could given the research
something out there yes it is really
great to have a what I would refer to as
a professional website for the podcast
yeah it is it is gorgeous I really like
it and we have working search
functionality to it which is super nice
now the search is the best makes it so
much easier to find content that you
really want to look at and it's pretty
it's really this pretty everything's
like two great photos we got some great
images James who's over at HD
Interactive yes who does all the graphic
design for all the pictures that show up
yeah it makes it a really nice visual
experience would have in your personal
highlights I really enjoyed the fact
that we got to bring franceska back
especially when he came back to talk
about Ag on us while we were at next
yeah that was great fun that was really
that was fun it's always now we're in
France s back and then another highlight
for me for the year it was meeting Grace
who was on our solution architects
podcast hey I'm totally picking
favorites but it's true she was it was
such a pleasure to meet her and now I'm
like I can't spend enough time hanging
out with her and talking about chocolate
clearly so I'm glad that grace Mallis
and was able to come on and talk to us
about solution architects with miles yes
a time that was definitely a highlight
for me out of all the other highlight
out of all the other colleges
we've had a lot of highlights in this
episode I would say it would be very
remiss if I didn't mention it but a
highlight for me definitely is having
you join me on the podcast thanks mark
it has been a fun time being on this
podcast I'm really glad that we were
able to do this yeah it's been it's been
an absolute delight and a pleasure I
cannot think of anyone who would not
have rather spent this year with thank
you same here
sort of no it was good I'm really glad
we were able to do this yeah last but
not least for us is where is everyone
gonna be it's the holidays so you won't
see me next year but you will see mark
again in 2019 and see by here meaning
listen he'll be back and everybody else
hopefully is having a good holiday we
want to thank a number of people and we
definitely want to thank our guests we
also want to thank Jennifer who has
helped us stay organized and scheduled
and on top of a number of things that we
have not been able to be on top of at
times we also want to thank HD
Interactive especially James who has
done some phenomenal work with our
editing and our visuals and Trey and
Sabrina and Sean as well who've done a
lot of work around our web presidents
and so forth thanks to Greg Greg Wilson
glorious a leader of
well for basically supporting the
podcast throughout everything that's
been going on
also thanks out to Neil and Chuck who
work on Shana who works on social
they're hugely hugely supportive of the
podcast they do a huge amount of work we
also want to thank in booth for the
website and the overhaul of the social
media support and last but not least we
want to thank franceska because you know
we have to thank friends esque he's out
there his presence is somewhere so he
gets really mad if you don't mention it
I know but yes no without without
franceska this would not have happened
as well in the first exactly mark I
think that's it for us thank you again
very much
it has been great experience and I'm
really glad you and I got to work
together this year me too
thank you to you and thank you to
everyone for listening as well yeah
great having listeners and get emails
and messages on Twitter and all that
good stuff so Happy New Year Happy
Holidays all that good stuff so we'll
see you all in January at some point
next year so stay tuned more to come and
yeah we'll see you all next year
[Music]